bonjour
lourd et riche aujourd'hui montpellier
pour la réunion des ministres
européens du développement
était à remercier
la france et au ministre jean-yves
d'audience mon ami d'adrien pour son
hospitalité
la réunion a été dominée par l'invasion
de l'ukraine à la russie
qui pose un énorme problème
humanitaire
l'armée russe
poursuit son offensive
en ukraine le nombre des civils tués on
monte le jour le jour et on est dans un
processus de destruction systématique
des infrastructures
pas seulement militaire mais sybille
c'est des habitations c'est
serré une facture civils qui sont prises
possible d'une façon systématique
évidemment ça n'a fait qu'augmenter
le nombre de réfugiés qui franchissent
les frontières de l'europe
déjà on a dépassé le chiffre de 1
million et demi c'est plutôt un million
six cent mille vous voyez quelle vitesse
ça on monte et on craint fort que la fif
c'est une estimation raisonnable
ça peut arriver à 5 millions de
personnes
on a vu
depuis la fin de la deuxième guerre
mondiale
un mouvement de réfugiés
aussi grand on s'est produit 100 aussi
vite
cette énorme quantité des gens qui
quitte son pays pour échapper à la
guerre
devront être accueillis par les pays
européens
il y à des estimations qui disent que
plus de 18 millions de personnes seront
touchées par les conflits à l'intérieur
de l'ukraine
on a discuté la réponse à cette
situation
nous avons identifié un premier
versement de presque 100 millions
d'euros pour une aide humanitaire
immédiate
à nos partenaires
en ukraine et en moldavie
c'est finalement
fédéral à fournir à nous redire en lots
santé des abris la protection des vases
pour ses citoyens ukrainiens
dans ce contexte nous allons remonter la
résilience de l'ukraine et de la
moldavie
la moldavie en particulier un pays qui
se sent menacé et qui a besoin d'une
aide à la fois économiques et politiques
on va travailler aussi rapidement pour
la mobilisation de un paquet de 500
millions d'euros pour l'ukraine qui a
été annoncé par la présidente de la
commission européenne pour aider les
populations touchées par le conflit
il faudra continuer à aider l'ukraine
dans les domaines de la sécurité de la
saveur security
mais l'important ce moment c
et d de flux' de réfugiés
j'ai continué à travailler pour essayer
de trouver
ces failles au le feu qu'ils puissent
commencer à ouvrir la porte à une
négociation
l'autre côté la réunion ils étaient
présentes la banque européenne
d'investissement
qui a décidé de réorienter
600 700 millions d'euros pour soutenir
la liquidité et l'économie ukrainienne
ça en ce qui fait référence au conflit
ukrainien
nous avons aussi avorté à une question
de caractère structurel c'est la
dimension géopolitique de l'europe
nous avons besoin de blanc demande d'une
façon ou d'une europe plusieurs
politiques y compris dans la façon de
concevoir
je vais faire de la coopération et du
développement
il nous faut clarté d'une opportunité
il nous faut faire mais t es une nouveau
crédibilité
il faut sortir de la logique des
annonces rhétorique est passé et des
offres concrètes et réalistes que nos
partenaires puissent prendre sur yeux et
qui soit susceptible de faire la
différence
oui nous voulons tous une rupture
politique
mais comment tout d'abord il faut être
plus affirmatif plus de terminer dans la
défense de nos valeurs et de nos
intérêts et l'accusant crânienne
agi comme un catalyseur
dans la recherche de cette europe
plusieurs politiques utilisent tous ses
moyens pour influencer sur le destin du
monde
pour influencer sur nos partenaires de
référence
il pour tenir compte de son pote dans
les nations unies pour savoir à quel
point se sont alignées avec les
positions que nous défendons
il prit finalement on a eu l'occasion
pendant le déjeuner de discuter sur le
problème des caractères global dont on
ne parle pas assez c'est la biodiversité
on parle beaucoup des changements
climatiques on parle beaucoup moins de
la perte de biodiversité
que nous avons eu l'occasion d'en
discuter de l'ancien président du niger
mais s'il échoue il souffre ou est un
ancien étudiant dans l'université de
montpellier sur la manière d'intégrer la
biodiversité dans les politiques
dead au développement ainsi que la
contribution que l'union européenne peut
faire à la recherche agricole en afrique
je compose paraître secondaire
n'ayant comme nous tous avant les yeux
braqués sur ce qui se passe en ukraine
mais elles sont pas secondaire
n'ont pas l'urgence les dramatisme de la
d'ukraine mais la perte de biodiversité
est un problème mondial
transversale qui nous touchent à tous et
qui va nous poser beaucoup de problèmes
à nos court terme
et donc
il faut supposer il faut y travailler
parce que la perte de biodiversité
c'est une grande menace pour le
développement durable
et pour l'objectif final de lutte contre
la pauvreté ça a été une discussion
passionnante mais je comprends fort bien
qu'aujourd'hui l'intérêt sur le cren se
pose à tous le conseil a voulu ouvrir un
récépissé à discussion sur le sujet
merci encore à la france
pour avoir accueilli cette encontre
merci à montpellier aussant espitalier